all right you know what okay why don't
we offer up some possible names for
some names all right
is there a a foreign way you can say
george is you know man oh good idea
hey yeah jorge george's georges
georgia french it has an s on it german
it has
just ends at the gym george pierre is
has an s in it
yeah um what would george's name and
like
like a filipino nickname be jorge would
it be jorge yeah yeah
what does your wife want to call him um
well she's rejected every name i gave
her so far i was going for
are you going george thomas charles that
was well she said it's not off the table
but you need to give me a good reason
for george thomas kimmel the fifth
oh okay okay but does she want to she
wants to name it completely
different give me give me five names
babe ash
um josh okay ash kimmel is a good name
mm-hmm uh dash dash
there's a theme smash
smash bash
no yeah yeah yeah bash bash camel
i like sebastian i don't like
yeah for sebastian basher that could be
his fool maybe something that you've
never heard before like doloroquoi see
that's closer along the lines of what i
want
yeah uh mukmok
my lord let's get a little frustrated
how about that meloriana
laureate nickname his name is what
allure
molar uh darrell
clemenca i don't know i can't spell it
yeah i can't spell it you can't spell
that yeah actually let me try that slink
slicken ma slick slickyampaka
okay well um so george
so now do we know um it's healthy yeah
good congratulations on that what kind
of test did they do on that
i don't know she goes into the hospital
every week since like they do weekly
tests and
everything's been good so far yeah but
can they can they dictate like
um tourette's no tourette's is something
that's either developed over time
okay i'm just asking i'm not trying to
make fun of anybody i'm just trying i
honestly don't know
yeah so please don't you know i mean
get mad at me yeah what what else are
you worried about i'm just worried okay
so what can i
fill george's mind with worries and
concerns that's not popular unique name
i'm over aiden aiden is
that too popular no not gross hey all
the aiden's listening you're wonderful
just like
kendrick's valdo that's awesome also
another name i really love george is
oscar
oscar is an awesome name osvaldo they're
they're good with the words
pretty good orson is a badass name too
rigs riggs is a good name these are the
top
rigs yeah yeah there's these right like
these are the top
that are unique but that are like like
hipsters are using right now
kind of yeah wow uh orson i like horses
pretty good
yeah um i like oscar aussie
i like aussie yeah wes
west i'm just gonna think of directors
you know i mean they have you know
all right try producing all the
producers maybe like producers like
weinstein
[Laughter]
how about harvey miramax wine
okay so we don't know so we obviously
they just
check check for um can they check for
stutter
no okay can they check for um
carpal tunnel no because that's
something that's acquired by doing
certain motions
oh see okay i'm just asking i don't know
can they acquire
um flat feet no okay
flat feet is something i think you're
born with your arch is there spinal
bifida
yes absolutely spinal buffer that they
can well
spina bifida is you can usually tell in
a baby because they have a little tuft
of hair
in the lower back or something and
there's
either there's different versions of
spina bifida but that's why you take
prenatals and all that stuff
prevent that interesting so healthy baby
that's exciting
do we know when it's coming uh yup uh
first week of april
ooh the first week oh that is so scary
that is so frightening it's almost like
i'm having a baby almost
we are having a baby as a first one it's
our first tiger belly baby yeah well
yeah congratulations might be the only
one gilbert are you
or we'll see if this force you have
plans the sports can stop something
do you have fears i think
i'm i am starting to get a little
worried now that i'm not ready
it's uh but i'm like waiting for the
last minute what are your fears in
regards to
actually like not even just like
obviously like the birth but beyond that
think once